[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Good morning, class.
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHALE FEE: Hey, let's
go ahead and get started.
So we're going to finish
spectral analysis today.
So we are going to learn how to
make a graphical representation
like this of the spectral and
temporal structure of time
series, or in this case,
a speech signal recorded
on a microphone.
Well, actually let
me just tell you
exactly what it is that
we're looking at here.
So this is a spectrogram that
displays the amount of power
in this signal as
a function of time
and as a function of frequency.
So you remember we've been
learning how to construct
the spectrum of a signal.
And today, we're
going to learn how
to construct a representation
like this, called
a spectrogram, that shows how
that spectrum varies over time.
So as you recall,
we have learned
how to compute the Fourier
transform of a signal.
This is one of the signals
that we actually started with.
So if you compute the Fourier
transform of this square wave,
you can see that in
the frequency domain,
now we plot the amount
of, essentially,
the components of this signal
at different frequencies.
So the Fourier transform
of this square wave
has a number of peaks.
Each of these peaks correspond
to a cosine contribution
to this time series, OK?
All right.
And we also
discussed how you can
compute the power
spectrum of a signal
from the Fourier transform.
So here what I've done
is I've taken the Fourier
transform of this square wave.
And now we take the
square magnitude
of each of these
values, and we just
plot the spectrum,
the square magnitude
of just the positive
frequency components.
For real-valued functions, the
power spectrum is symmetric.
The power in each of these--
at each of these frequencies
in the positive, half of the--
for the positive frequencies
is exactly the same
as the power in the
negative frequencies.
So if we plot the power
spectrum of that square wave,
we can see that there
are multiple peaks
at regular intervals.
Now the problem with plotting
power spectra on a linear scale
here is that you often
have contributions--
important contributions to
signals that actually have
a very small amount of
power when you plot them
on a linear scale.
And so you can barely see them.
You can barely see
those contributions
at these frequencies
here on a linear scale.
But if you plot
this on a log scale,
you can see the spectrum
much more easily.
So for example,
what we've done here
is we've plotted the square
magnitude of the Fourier
transform, taken the log
base 10 of that spectrum--
spectrum is the square magnitude
of the Fourier transform.
And now we can take the log
base 10 of the power spectrum
to get the power
in units of bels,
and multiply that by 10 to get
the power in units of decibels,
OK?
So each tick mark here
of size 10 corresponds
to one order of
magnitude in power, OK?
So this peak here is about 10
dB lower than that peak there,
and that corresponds to about
a factor of 10 lower in power.
OK, any questions about that?
I want to be able-- want
you to understand what
these units of decibels are.
They're going to be on the test.
OK.
Questions about that?
You want to just
ask me right now?
OK.
Remember this.
And keep in mind that
the power in a signal
is proportional to the
square of the amplitude, OK?
So if I tell you that a signal
has 10 times as much amplitude,
it's going to have 100
times as much power.
100 times as much
power is 10 to the 2
bels, which is 20 decibels.
Does that make sense?
OK.
All right.
So we also talked about
some Fourier transforms
of different kinds of functions.
So this is the Fourier
transform of a square pulse.
So here I showed
you a square pulse
that has a width of
100 milliseconds.
The Fourier transform
is this sinc function,
and for a square pulse of
width 100 milliseconds,
the sinc function has a half--
sorry-- has a full width
at half height of 12 hertz.
If we have a square pulse
that's five times as long,
500 milliseconds long,
the Fourier transform
is the sinc function
again, but it
has a width of this central
lobe here of 2.4 hertz.
So you can see that the longer
the pulse, the shorter--
the narrower the structure
in the frequency domain.
Up here, if we'd look
at the Fourier transform
of a square pulse that's
25 milliseconds long,
then the Fourier transform
is again a sinc function,
and the width of that
central lobe is 48 hertz.
So you can see that the
width in the time domain
and the width in the frequency
domain are inversely related.
So the product of the
width in the time domain
and the width in the
frequency domain is constant.
And that constant is called
the time-bandwidth product
of that signal.
The time-bandwidth product
of this square pulse
and sinc function is constant.
It's independent of the width.
The time-bandwidth product
is a function of that.
It's a characteristic
of that functional form.
OK.
Now we also talked about
the convolution theorem,
which relates the way signals
get multiplied in time
or convolved in
frequency domain.
So for example, if we have a
square pulse in time multiplied
by a cosine function in time
to get a windowed cosine--
so this function
is zero everywhere
except it's cosine
within this window--
we can compute the
Fourier transform
of this windowed cosine function
by convolving the Fourier
transform of the square
pulse with the Fourier
transform of the cosine
function, like this.
So the Fourier transform
of the square pulse
is, again, this sinc function.
The Fourier transform
of the cosine
are these two delta functions.
Now if we convolve the sinc
function with those two delta
functions, we get a copy
of that sinc function
at the location of each
of those delta functions.
And that is the
Fourier transform, OK?
Any questions about that?
Just a quick review of things
we've been talking about.
All right.
So we can look at this
Fourier transform here.
We can look at
the power spectrum
of this windowed cosine
function, like this.
So there's the windowed
cosine function.
The power spectrum--
the power spectrum
plotted on a linear scale
is just the square magnitude
of what I've plotted here.
And we're just going to plot
the positive frequencies.
That's what the power
spectrum of that signal
looks like on a log scale.
So you can see
that it has a peak
at 20 hertz, which
was the frequency
of the cosine function.
You see some little
wiggles out here.
But if you look on
a log scale, you
can see that those
wiggles off to the side
are actually quite significant.
The first side lobe there
has a power that's about 1/10
of the central peak.
That may not matter,
sometimes, when
you're looking at the
spectrum of a signal,
but sometimes it will matter
because those side lobes
there will interfere.
They'll mask the spectrum of
other components of this signal
that you may be interested in.
We also talked about
how this spectrum
depends on the function that you
multiply your cosine by here.
So for example, if
you take a cosine
and you multiply it by
Gaussian, the power spectrum
has the shape of
a Gaussian, it's
a Gaussian that has
a peak at 20 hertz.
And if you look at the--
if you look at that
spectrum on a log scale,
you can see that it loses it--
you've lost all of these
high-frequency wiggles,
up here.
All of those wiggles
come from the sharp edge
of this square pulse
windowing function, OK?
So the shape of the
spectrum that you get
depends a lot on how
you window the function
that you're looking at.
Questions about that?
Right, again, more review.
OK.
So we talked about estimating
the spectrum of a signal.
If you have many different
measurements of some signal,
you can actually just compute
the spectrum of each one.
This little hat here means
an estimate of the spectrum.
You compute some estimate
of the spectrum of each
of those trials,
samples of your data,
and you can just average
of those together.
OK, now if you have a continuous
signal, you can also--
you could estimate
the spectrum just
by taking the Fourier
transform of a long recording
of your signal.
But it's much better to break
your signal into small pieces,
compute a spectral estimate of
each one of those small pieces
and average those together.
Now how do you construct a
small sample of a signal?
If you have a continuous
signal, how do you
take a small sample of it?
Well, you can think
about that as taking
your continuous signal
and multiplying it
by a square window.
Setting everything outside
that window to zero
and just keeping the part
that's in that window.
And you know that
when you take a signal
and you multiply it by a square
window, what have you done?
You've convolved the spectrum
of this original signal
with the spectrum of
this square pulse.
And that spectrum
of the square pulse
is really a nasty
looking thing, right?
It is this what we call the
Dirichlet kernel, which is just
the power spectrum
of a square pulse
that we just talked about, OK?
So that's called the
Dirichlet kernel.
And using a square pulse to
select out a sample of data
introduces two errors into
your spectral estimate,
narrowband bias.
It broadens your estimate of
the spectrum of, let's say,
sinusoidal or periodic
components in your signal.
And it also introduces
these side lobes.
So the way we solve
that problem is
we break our signal
into little pieces,
multiply each of
those little pieces
by a smoother windowing
function by something
that isn't a square
pulse, multiply it
by something that maybe
looks like a Gaussian, or a--
or half of a cosine function.
That gives us what we call
tapered segments of our data.
We can estimate the spectrum
of those tapered pieces
and averaged those together, OK?
Any questions?
OK, again, that's a review.
And I showed you briefly
what happens if we
take a little piece of signal.
The blue is white
noise with a little bit
of this periodic sine
function added to it.
And if you run
that analysis, you
can see that there is a large
component of the spectrum
that's due to the white noise.
That's this broadband
component here.
And that sinusoidal
component there gives you
this peak in the spectrum, OK?
And there's a--
I've posted-- or Daniel's
posted a function
called wspec.m that implements
this spectral estimate
like this.
So now today, we're going to
turn to estimating time varying
signals, estimating the spectrum
of time varying signals.
So this is a microphone
recording of a speech signal.
Let me see if I can play that.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Hello.
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHALE FEE: All right.
So that's just me saying
hello in a robotic voice.
OK.
So that is the signal.
That's basically
voltage recorded
on the output of a microphone.
It's got some interesting
structure in it, right?
So first these
little pulses here,
you see this kind
of periodic pulse.
Those are called glottal pulses.
Does anyone know what those are?
What produces those?
No?
OK, so when you
speak a voiced sound,
your vocal cords are vibrating.
You have two pieces
of flexible tissue
that are close to each
other in your trachea.
As air flows up
through your trachea,
the air pressure builds up and
pushes the glottal folds apart.
Air begins to flow rapidly
through that open space.
At high velocities,
the velocity flowing
through the constriction is
higher than the velocity of air
anywhere else in the
trachea because it's flowing
through a tiny little space.
At high velocities,
at constrictions
where you have a
high fluid flow,
the pressure actually drops.
And that pulls the vocal
folds back together again.
When they snap together,
all the airflow stops,
and you have a pulse of negative
pressure above the glottis,
right?
Imagine you have
airflow coming up.
And all of a sudden,
you pinch it off.
There's a sudden drop in the
pressure as that mass of air
keeps flowing up, but there's
nothing more coming up below.
So you get a sharp
drop in the pressure.
Then the air pressure
builds up again.
The glottal folds open,
velocity increases,
and they snap shut again.
And so that's what happens
as you're talking, OK?
And so that periodic
signal right there, those
pulses in pressure--
the microphone is
recording pressure, remember.
So those pulses are due
to your glottis snapping
shut each time it
closes during the cycle,
during that oscillatory cycle.
The period of that--
those glottal pulses
is about 10 milliseconds in
men and about 5 milliseconds
in women.
OK.
But you can see there's
a lot of other structure
changes in this signal
that go on through time.
But let's start by just
looking at the spectrum
of that whole signal.
Now what might we expect?
So if you have periodic pulses
at 10 millisecond period,
what should the
spectrum look like?
If you have a train of pulses,
let's say delta functions
with 10 millisecond period, what
would the spectrum of that look
like?
Anybody remember what the
spectrum of a train of pulses
looks like?
Almost, yes.
There would be.
But there would be
other things as well.
What would a signal
look like that just
has a peak at 100 hertz?
What is that?
Has one peak at 100 hertz?
Or let's say [INAUDIBLE]
Fourier transform would have
a peak at 100 and at minus 100.
That's just a cosine.
That's not a train of pulses.
What's the Fourier transform
of a train of pulses?
Those of you who are
concentrating on this right
now are going to be really
glad on the midterm.
What's the Fourier transform
of a train of pulses?
OK, let's go back to
here because there
was a bit of a hint here at
the beginning of lecture.
What's the Fourier
transform of a square wave?
Any idea what happens if we
make these pulses narrower
and narrower?
The pulses get more
and more narrow,
these peaks get
bigger and bigger.
And as we go to a train
of delta functions,
you just get Fourier
transform of a train
of delta functions
in time, is just
a train of delta
functions in frequency.
The spacing between the
peaks in frequency is just 1
over the spacing between
the peaks in time, right?
Make sure you know that.
OK, so now let's go back
to our speech signal.
These are almost
like delta functions.
Maybe not quite, but for
now, let's pretend they are.
If those are a train of
delta functions spaced
at 10 milliseconds, what is our
spectrum going to look like?
I just said it.
What is it going to look like?
Yep.
Spaced by?
AUDIENCE: One.
MICHALE FEE: Which is?
100 hertz.
Good.
So here's the spectrum
of that speech signal.
What do you see?
You see a train of delta
functions separated
by about 100 hertz, right?
That's a kilohertz, that's
500 hertz, that's 100 hertz.
So you get a train of
delta functions separated
by 100 hertz, OK?
That's called a harmonic stack.
OK.
And the spectrum
of a speech signal
has a harmonic stack
because the signal has
these short little pulses
of pressure in them.
OK, what are these bumps here?
Why is there a bump here, a
bump here, and a bump here?
Does anyone know that?
What is it that shapes
the sound as you speak?
That makes an "ooh" sound
different from an "ahh?"
[INAUDIBLE] This is hello.
Sorry, I'm having
trouble with my pointer.
That's hello.
What is it that makes all
things sound different?
So the sound, those
pulses, are made down
hearing your vocal tract.
As those pulses propagate
up from your glottis
to your lips, they [AUDIO OUT]
filter, which is your mouth.
And that the shape
of that filter
is controlled by the
closure of your lips,
by where your tongue is, where
different parts of your tongue
are closing the
opening in your mouth.
And all of those things produce
filters that have peaks.
And the vocal filter
has three main peaks
that move around as you move
the shape of your mouth.
And those are
called formants, OK?
OK.
Now you can see that
this temporal structure,
this spectral structure
isn't constant in time.
It changes-- right--
throughout this word.
So what we can do is we
can take that signal,
and we can compute the spectrum
of little parts of it, OK?
So we can take that signal
and multiply it by a window
here, a taper here, and get
a little sample of the speech
signal and calculate
the spectrum of it
just by Fourier
transforming, OK?
We can do the same thing.
Shift it over a little bit
and compute the spectrum
of that signal, all right?
So we're going to take a
little piece of the signal that
has width in time, capital T--
OK-- that's the
width of the window.
We're going to multiply it by
a taper, compute the spectrum.
And we're going to
shift that window
by a smaller amount,
delta t, so that you
have overlapping windows.
Compute the spectrum
of each one,
and then stack all of
those up next to each other
So now you've got a spectrum
that's a function of time
and frequency, OK?
So each column is the
spectrum of one little piece
of the sound at
one moment in time.
Does that make sense?
OK.
And that's where this
spectrogram comes from.
Here in this
spectrogram, you can
see these horizontal striations
are the harmonics stack
produced by the glottal pulse.
This is a really
key way that people
study the mechanisms of
sound production and speech,
and animals vocalizations,
and all kinds of signals,
more generally, OK?
All right, any
questions about that?
All right.
Now what's really cool
is that you can actually
focus on different
things in a signal, OK?
So for example, if I
compute the spectrogram
with signals where that little
window that I'm choosing
is really long, then I
have high frequency--
high resolution and
frequency, and the spectrogram
looks like this.
But if I compute
the spectrograph
with little windows in
time that are very short,
then my frequency
resolution is very poor,
but the temporal
resolution is very high.
And now you can
see the spectrum.
You can see these
vertical striations.
Those vertical
striations correspond
to pulse of the glottal pulse.
And we can basically see the
spectrum of each pulse coming
through the vocal tract.
Pretty cool, right?
So how you compute the
spectrum depends on
whether you're
actually interested in.
If you want to focus
on the glottal pulses,
for example, the
pitch of the speech
you look with a longtime window.
If you want to focus
on the formants,
here you can see the
performance very nicely,
you would use shorttime window.
Any questions?
So now I'm going to talk more
about the kinds of tapers
that you use to get the best
possible spectral estimate.
So a perfect taper, in
a sense would give you
perfect temporal resolution.
It would give you really
fine temporal resolution.
And it would give you really
fine frequency resolution,
but because there is a
fundamental limit on the time
bandwidth product, you can't
measure frequency infinitely
well with an infinitely
short sample of a signal.
Imagine you have a
sine wave, and you
took like two samples
of a sine wave.
It would be really hard to
figure out the frequency,
whereas if you have many, many,
many samples of a sine wave,
you can figure
out the frequency.
So there's a
fundamental limit there.
So there's no such thing
as a perfect taper.
If I want to take a
sample of my signal
in time, if I have a sample
that's limited in time,
if it goes from one
time to another time
and a zero outside of
that, then in frequency,
it's spread out to infinity.
And so all we can do
is choose how it is.
We can either have
things look worse in time
and better in frequency or
better in time and worse
in frequency.
So the other problem is
that when we taper a signal,
we're throwing away
data here at the edges.
But if you take a square window
and you keep all the data
within that square
window, well, you've
got all the data in that window.
But as soon as you
taper it, you're
throwing away
stuff at the edges.
So you taper it
to make it smooth
and improve the spectrum,
the spectral estimate,
but you're throwing away data.
So you can actually
compute the optimal taper.
Here's how you do that.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to think of this
as what's called
the spectral
concentration problem.
We're going to
find a function W.
This is a tapering
that is limited
in time from some
minus T/2 to plus T/2.
So it's 0 outside of that.
It concentrates
the maximum amount
of energy in it's
Fourier Transform,
in its power spectrum within
a window that has widths 2W.
So W is this [INAUDIBLE].
Does that makes sense?
We're going to find
a function w that
concentrates as much energy
as possible in square window.
And of course, that's
going to have the result
that the energy
in the side lobes
is going to be as
small as possible.
And there are many
different optimizations
you can do in principle.
But this particular optimization
is about getting as much
of the power as possible
into a central low.
Here's this function of time.
We simply calculate the
Fourier Transform of W.
We call that U of f.
And now we just write
down a parameter that
says how much of that Fourier--
how much of the power in U
is in the window from minus
w to w compared to how
much power there is in U
overall, overall frequencies?
So if lambda is 1,
then all of the power
is between minus w and w.
Does that make sense?
So you can actually solve this
optimization problem, maximize
lambda, and what you find
is that there's not just one
function that gives very good
concentration of the power
into this band.
There's actually a
family of functions.
There's actually k
of these functions,
where k is twice the
bandwidth times the duration
of the window minus 1.
So there are a
family of k functions
called Slepian functions
for which lambda
is very close to 1.
There are also discrete probate
spheroid sequence functions,
dpss.
And that's the command
that Matlab uses
to find those functions dpss.
Here's what they look like.
So these are five functions
that give lambda close
to 1 or for a particular
bandwidth in a particular time
window.
The n equals 1 function
is a single peak.
It looks a lot like a Gaussian,
but it's not a Gaussian.
What's fundamentally different
between this function
and a Gaussian?
This function goes to 0
outside that time window,
whereas a Gaussian
goes on forever.
The second slepian
in this family
has a peak, a positive
peak in the left half,
a negative peak in the right.
The third one has positive,
negative, positive,
and then goes to 0.
And the higher order functions
just have more wiggle.
They all have the property
that they go to 0 at the edges.
And the other
interesting properties
that these functions are all
orthogonal to each other.
That means if you multiply this
function times that function
and integrate, you get 0.
Multiply any two of these
functions and integrate
over the window
minus T/2 to plus T/2
the integral [INAUDIBLE]
What that means is that
the spectral estimate you
get by windowing your data
with each of these functions
separately are
statistically independent.
You actually have multiple
different estimates
of the spectrum from
the same little piece
of [AUDIO OUT] The
other cool thing is
that remember the problem
with windowing our [AUDIO OUT]
with one peak like this
is we were throwing away
data at the edges.
Well, notice that the higher
order slepian functions
have big peaks at the edges.
And so they are actually
measuring the spectrum
of the parts of the signal that
are at the edge of the window.
Now notice that those functions
start crashing into the edges.
So you start getting sharp,
sharp edges out here,
which is why the higher order
functions have worse ripples
outside that central lobe.
Any questions about that?
It's a lot [AUDIO OUT]
Just remember
that for a given width
of the window in time
and within frequency, there
are multiple of these functions
that put the maximum amount
of power in this window 2W.
So that's great.
So good question.
What would you do if you're
trying to measure something
and you measure it
five different times,
how would you get an estimate
of what the actual number is?
How would you get an error bar
on how good your estimate is?
For deviation of your
estimates, right.
And that's exactly what you do.
So not only can you
get a good estimate
of the average spectrum by
averaging all of these things
together, but you can
actually get an error bar.
And that's really cool.
So here's the
procedure that you use.
And this is what's in that
little function W spec.m.
So you select a time window
of a particular width.
How do you know
what with to choose?
That's part of it.
The other thing is if your
signal is changing rapidly
in time and you actually
care about that change,
you should choose--
you're more interested
in temporal resolution.
If your signal is
really constant,
like it doesn't
change very fast,
then you can use bigger windows.
So we're going to
choose a time width.
Then what you're
going to do is you're
going to select this
parameter p, which is just
the time-bandwidth product
And if you've already
chosen T, what you're doing
is you're just choosing
the frequency resolution.
Once you compute
p and you know T,
you just stuff those numbers
into this Matlab function
dpss, which sends back to you
this set of functions here.
It sends you back k of those
functions that once you've
chosen p, k is just 2p minus 1.
And then what do you do?
You just take your
little snippet of data.
You multiply it by the first
taper, compute the spectrum,
compute the Fourier Transform.
And then take your
little piece of data,
multiply it by the second one,
compute the Fourier transform,
and the power spectrum.
And then you're just
going to average.
This square magnitude
should be inside the window,
your piece of data.
You Fourier transform it, square
magnitude, and then average
all those spectra together.
I see this is Fourier
transform right here.
This sum is the
Fourier transform that.
We square magnitude that to
get the spectral estimate
of that particular sample.
Then we're going to average
that spectrum together
for all the different
windowing tapering function.
Now you get then multiple
spectral estimates.
You're going to average them
together to get the mean.
And you can also
look at the variance
to get the standard deviation.
Questions?
Let's stop there.
That was that was
a lot of stuff.
Let's take a breath and
[INAUDIBLE] to see whether we
[AUDIO OUT] Questions?
No.
Don't worry about it.
This is representation
of the Fourier transform.
You sum over all
the time samples.
This, you will just do as
fast Fourier transform.
So you'll take the
data, multiply it
by this taper function,
which is the slepian
and then do the
Fourier transform, take
the square magnitude.
We just want make sure that
we've got the basic idea.
So you've got a
long piece of data.
You're going to lose some
time window, capital T. You're
going to choose a bandwidth W or
this time bandwidth product p.
Bend T and p to
this dpss function.
It will send you back a bunch
of these dpss functions that
fit in that window.
Now you're going to
take your piece of data.
You're going to break it into
little windows of that length,
multiply them by each one
of the slepian functions
Do the Fourier transform of
each one of those products.
Average them all altogether.
Take the square magnitude of
each one to get the spectrum,
and then average all
those spectra together.
So now so what does
p do? p chooses
bandwidth of the slepian
function in that window.
So if you have a window
that's 100 milliseconds wide--
so we're going to take
our data and break it
into little pieces
that's milliseconds long.
It's goes from minus 50
to plus 50 milliseconds.
Choose a window that
has a narrow bandwidth,
the small p, then the
bandwidth is narrow.
The bandwidth is narrow,
because the function is wide,
or you can choose
a large bandwidth.
What does that mean?
It's a narrower
function in time.
Now if p is 5, you have
a broader bandwidth.
And that means that the
window, the tapering function
is narrower in time.
Look at the Fourier
transform of each of two
different tapering functions.
You can see that
if p equals 1.5,
the tapering function is broad.
But that Fourier transform,
a kernel in frequency space
is narrower.
Take the p equals 5 function,
a broader bandwidth,
it's narrower in time
and broader in frequency.
Does that makes sense?
p just for a given
size time window
tells you how many
different samples
we're going to take
within that time window.
no
So let me just go back to
this example right here.
So I took this speech signal
that I just showed you
that was recorded
on the microphone.
I chose a time window
of 50 milliseconds.
So I broke the
speech signal down
into little 50
millisecond chunks.
I chose a bandwidth of 60 hertz.
That corresponds to p
equals 1.5 and k equals 2.
That gives me back a bunch
of these little functions.
And I computed this spectragram.
For this spectragram, I chose
a shorter time window, eight
milliseconds, choose a
bandwidth of 375 hertz, which
also corresponds to p
equals 1.5 and k equals 2.
And if you Fourier
transform the spectragram
with those parameters, you
get this example right here.
So in this case,
I kept the same p,
the same time-bandwidth product,
but I made the time shorter.
So the best way to do this,
when you're actually doing this,
practically is just
to take a signal
by some of these different
things [INAUDIBLE]
That's really the
best way to do it.
You can't-- I don't recommend
trying to think through
beforehand too much exactly what
it's going to look like if you
choose these different values
when it's easier just to try
different things and
see what it looks like.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What are looking for?
MICHALE FEE: Well, it
depends on what you're
trying to get out of the data.
If you want to
visualize formants,
you can see that the
formants are much clearer.
These different windows give you
a different view on the data.
So just look through
different windows
and see what looks
interesting in the results.
That's the best way to do it.
So I just want to
say one more word
about this
time-bandwidth product.
So the time-bandwidth product of
any function is greater than 1.
So you can make time shorter,
but bandwidth is worse.
The way that you
can think about this
as that you're sort of
looking at your data
through a window in
time and frequency.
What you want is to look with
infinitely fine resolution
in both time and
frequency, but really you
can't have infinite time
and frequency resolution.
You're going to be smearing
your view of the data
with something that
has a minimum area,
the time-bandwidth product which
has a minimum of size of 1.
You can either make time small
and stretch the bandwidth out,
or you can stretch out time
and make the bandwidth shorter
or make time short and
make the bandwidth long.
But you can't squeeze
both, because of
this fundamental limit on
the time bandwidth product.
This all depends on
how you're measuring
the time and the bandwidth.
These are kind of
funny shaped functions.
So there are different
ways of measure
what the bandwidth
of a signal is
or what the time
width of a signal is.
Now, the windows that you're
looking in time and frequency
with are the smallest
time bandwidth product.
So notice that if the
time-bandwidth product is
small, close to 1,
the number of tapers
you get in this dpss, this
family of functions you get
is just 1.
If p is 1, then k is
2P minus 1, which is 1.
So you only get one window.
You only get one
estimate of the spectrum,
but you can also choose
to look at your data
with worse, [AUDIO OUT] that
have a worse time frequency
time-bandwidth product.
Why would you do that?
Why would you ever
look at your data
with functions that have a
worse time-bandwidth product?
Well, notice that if the
time-bandwidth product is 2,
how many functions do you have?
Why does that matter,
because now you
have three independent estimates
of what that spectrum is.
So sometimes you
would gladly choose
to have a worse resolution
in time and frequency,
because you've got more
independent estimates means
better.
So sometimes your signal
might be changing very slowly.
And then you can use a big
time-bandwidth product.
It doesn't matter.
Sometimes your signal is
changing very rapidly in time.
And so you want to keep the
time-bandwidth product small.
Does that begin to [INAUDIBLE]
bigger time-bandwidth products
and now you get even more
independent estimates.
Most typically, you choose p's
that go from 1.5 to multiples
of 0.5, because then you have
an integer number of k's.
But usually, you choose
p equals 1.5 or higher
in multiples of 0.5.
If you really care about
temporal resolution
and frequency resolution,
you want that box
that's smearing
out your spectrum
to be as small as possible.
Small as possible means
it has an area of 1.
That's the minimum
area it can have,
but that only gives
you one taper.
But if you really care about
both temporal and frequency--
time and frequency
resolution, then that's
the trade-off you have to make.
Slowly you can air out more in
time, maybe more in frequency,
and you can choose your
time-bandwidth product,
in which case you get
more tapers and a better
estimate of the spectrum.
So this is state of the
art spectral estimation.
It doesn't get better than this.
To put it like this, you're
doing it the best possible way,
a bit of digesting.
So lets spend the
rest of the lecture
today talking about filtering.
So Matlab has a bunch of really
powerful filtering tools.
So here's an example
of the kind of thing
where we use filtering.
So this is a [INAUDIBLE] finch
song recorded in the lab.
OK, so now I want
you to just listen--
so you were probably
listening to the song,
but now listen at
very low frequencies.
Tell me what you hear.
Listen at very low frequen--
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[FINCH CHIRPING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[HUMS]
--background, that's hum
from the building's air
conditioners, air handling.
It all makes this low rumbling,
which adds a lot of noise
to the signal that can
make it hard to see
where the syllables are in
the [AUDIO OUT] time series.
Here are the
syllables right here.
And that's the background noise.
But the background noise
is at very low frequencies.
So sometimes you want to
just filter stuff like that
away because we don't care
about the air conditioner.
We care about the bird's song.
OK, so we can get rid of that by
applying-- what kind of filter
would we apply to
this signal to get rid
of these low frequencies?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: A high pass.
MICHALE FEE: A high-pass
filter, very good.
OK, so let's put a high
pass filter on this.
Now, in the past,
previously we've
talked about using convolution
to carry out a high pass
filtering function.
But Matlab has all these
very powerful tools.
So I wanted to show you
what those look like
and how to use them.
OK, so this is a
little piece of code
that implements a high-pass
filter on that signal.
Now, you can see that all
of that low frequency stuff
is [AUDIO OUT] You have a
nice clean, silent background.
And now you can
see the syllables
on top of that background.
Here's the spectrogram.
You can see that all of that
low frequency stuff is gone.
And this is a little
bit of sample code here.
I just want to point
out a few things.
You give it the Nyquist
frequency, which is just
the sampling rate divided by 2.
I'll explain later
what that means.
You set a cutoff frequency.
So you tell it to cut
off below 500 hertz.
You put the cutoff and
Nyquest frequency together,
you get a ratio of
those two that's
basically the fraction
of the spectral width
that you're going to cut off.
And then you tell it to
give you the parameters
for a Butterworth filter.
It's just one of the kinds
of filters that you use.
Tell it whether it's a
high-pass or low-pass.
Send that filter, those filter
parameters, to this function
called filtfilt. You give it
these two parameters, B and A,
and your data vector.
And when run that, that's what
the result looks like, OK?
Let me play that again
for you after filtering.
All that low
frequency hum is gone.
All right, so here's
an example of what--
I mean, we would never
actually do this in the lab.
But this is what it would look
like if you wanted to emphasize
that low frequency stuff.
Let's say that you're the air
conditioner technician who
comes and wants to
figure out what's
wrong with the air conditioner.
And it turns out that the way
it sounds really is helpful.
So you now do a low-pass filter.
And you're going to keep
the low frequency part.
Because all those annoying
birds are making it hard
for you to hear what's wrong
with the air conditioner.
OK, so here's--
Didn't quite get
rid of the birds.
But now you can hear the low
frequency stuff much better.
OK, all right, so now we
just did that by, again,
giving it the Nyquist.
The cutoff, we're going
to cut off above 2,000,
pass below 2,000.
We're going to tell it to
use a Butterworth filter, now
low-pass.
And again, we just pass it
the parameters and the data.
And it sends us back
the filtered data.
OK, you can also do a band-pass.
OK, so a band-pass does a
high-pass and a low-pass
together.
Now you're filtering out
everything above some number
and below some number.
And here we give it a
cutoff with two numbers.
So it's going to
cut off everything
below 4 kilohertz and
everything above 5 kilohertz.
Again, we use the
Butterworth filter.
You leave off the tag to
get a band-pass filter.
And here's what
that sounds like.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[BIRDS CHIRPING]
[END PLAYBACK]
And thats a band-pass filter.
Questions?
Yeah, so there are
many different ways
to do this kind of filtering.
Daniel, do you know how filtfilt
actually implements this?
Because Matlab has a bunch of
different filtering functions.
And this is just one of them.
[INAUDIBLE] how it's actually
implemented [AUDIO OUT]
Right, so there's
a filt function,
which actually does a
convolution in one direction.
And filtfilt does the
convolution one direction
and then the other direction.
And what that does
it [AUDIO OUT]
output center with respect to
the input, centered [AUDIO OUT]
Anyway, there are
different ways of doing it.
And the nice thing about--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Well,
for the bird data,
it doesn't necessarily
make all that much sense,
right, on the face of it?
But there are
applications where there's
some signal at that
particular band.
So for example, let's say
you had a speech signal
and you wanted to find out
when the formants cross
a certain frequency.
Let's say you wanted to find
out if somebody could learn
to speak [AUDIO OUT] if you
blocked one of their formants
whenever it comes through
a particular frequency.
OK, so let's say I
have my second formant
and every time it
crosses 2 kilohertz
I play a burst of noise.
And I ask, can I
understand if I've knocked
out that particular formant?
I don't know why
you'd want to do that.
But maybe it's fun, right?
So I don't know, it
might be kind of cool.
So then you would run a
band-pass filter right
over 2-kilohertz band.
And now, you'd get a big signal
whenever that formant passed
through that band, right?
And then you would send
that to an amplifier
and play a noise burst
into the person's ear.
All right, we do things
like that with birds
to find out if they can learn
to shift the pitch of their song
in response to errors.
OK, so yes, they can.
Yes--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Formants
are the peaks
in the filter that's
formed by your vocal tract
by the [AUDIO OUT] air channel
from your glottis to your lips.
The location of those peaks
changes [INAUDIBLE] So ahh,
ooh, the difference
between those
is just the location
of those formant peaks.
All those things just have
formants at different location.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: So explain
a little bit more what
you mean by analog interference.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Oh,
OK, like 60 hertz.
OK, so that's a great question.
So let's say that you're
doing an experiment.
And you [AUDIO OUT]
contamination
of your signal by 60 hertz
noise from the outlet.
OK, it's really better to
spend the time to figure out
how to get rid of that noise.
But let's say that you
[INAUDIBLE] advisor your data
[AUDIO OUT] quite figured out
how to get rid of the 60 hertz
yet [AUDIO OUT] How would you
get rid of the 60 hertz from
your signal?
You could make what's called
a band-stop filter where
you suppress frequencies
within a particular band.
Put that band-stop
filter at 60 hertz.
The thing is, it's
very hard to make
a very narrow band-stop filter.
So we learned this
in the last lecture.
How would you get rid of a
particular [AUDIO OUT] Yeah,
so take the Fourier
transform of your signal,
that 60 hertz [AUDIO OUT] one
particular value of the Fourier
transform.
And you can just
set that [AUDIO OUT]
Because the filtering
in that case
would be knocking
down a whole band
of [AUDIO OUT] frequencies.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Well, it's
just that with filtfilt,
like I said, there are many
different ways of doing things.
filtfilt won't do that for you.
But once you know this stuff
that we've been learning,
you can go in and do stuff.
You don't have to have some
Matlab function to do it.
You just know how it
all works and you just
write a program to do it.
OK, that's pretty cool, right?
All right-- oh, and here's
the band-stop filter.
[INAUDIBLE] that
lag there stop, OK?
OK, let's keep going.
Oh, and there's a tool
here that's part of Matlab.
It's called a filter
visualization tool, FV tool.
You just run this and you
can select different kinds
of filters that have
different kinds of roll-off
in frequency, that have
different properties
in the time domain.
It's kind of fun to play with.
If you have to do
filtering on some signal,
just play around with this.
Because there are a bunch of
different kind of filters that
have different weird names
like Butterworth and Chebyshev
and a bunch of other things
that have different properties.
But you can actually just
play around with this
and design your own filter
to meet your own [AUDIO OUT]
OK, so I want to end by spending
a little bit of time talking
about some really cool things
about the Fourier transform
and talk about the
Nyquist Shannon theorem.
This is really kind
of mind boggling.
It's pretty cool.
So all right, so remember
that when you take the Fourier
transform-- the fast Fourier
transform of something--
[INAUDIBLE] take the
Fourier transform
of something analytically,
the Fourier transform
is defined continuously.
At every value of F,
there's a Fourier transform.
But when we do fast
Fourier transforms,
we've discretized time and we've
discretized frequency, right?
So when we take the
fast Fourier transform,
we get answer back where we
have a value of the Fourier
transform at a bunch of
discrete frequencies.
So frequency is discretized.
And we have frequencies,
little samples
of the spectrum at
different frequencies,
that are separated
by a little delta f.
[INAUDIBLE] What does that mean?
Remember when we were
doing a Fourier series?
What was it that we had to have
to write down a Fourier series
where we can write
down an approximation
to a function as a sum of
sine waves and multiples
of a common frequency?
What was it about
the signal in time
that allowed us to do that?
It's periodic.
We could only do that if
the signal is periodic.
So when we write down our fast
Fourier transform of a signal,
it's discretized in
time and frequency.
What that means is that
it's periodic in time.
So when we pass a signal that
we've sampled of some duration
and the fast Fourier transform
algorithm passes back
a spectrum that's discreted in
frequency, what that means is
that you can think
about that signal
as being periodic in time, OK?
Now, when you discretize
the signal in time,
you've taken samples
of that signal
in time separated by delta t.
What does that tell
you about the spectrum?
So when we pass the
Fourier transform
FFT algorithm, a signal
that's discretized in time,
it passes us back this
thing here, right,
with positive frequencies
in the first half
of the vector, the negative
frequencies in the second half.
It's really a piece--
it's one period of
a periodic spectrum.
[AUDIO OUT] right?
Mathematically, if our signal
is discretized in time,
it means the
spectrum is periodic.
And the FFT algorithm is
passing back one period.
And then there's a circular
shift to get this thing.
Does that makes sense?
OK, now, because these
are real functions,
this piece here is exactly
equal to that piece.
It's symmetric.
The magnitude of the
spectrum is symmetric.
So what does that mean?
What that means, if our
signal has some bandwidth--
if the highest frequency is
less than some bandwidth B--
if the sampling
rate is high enough,
then you can see that the
frequency components here
don't interact with the
frequency components here.
You can see that
they're separated.
OK, one more thing.
The period of a spectrum 1 is
over delta t [INAUDIBLE] which
is equal to the sampling rate.
So when we have a signal
that's discretized in time,
the spectrum is periodic and
there are multiple copies
of that spectrum,
of this spectrum,
at intervals of
[AUDIO OUT] rate.
OK, so if the sampling
rate is high enough,
then the positive
frequencies are well
separated from the
negative frequencies
if the sampling rate is higher
than twice the bandwidth
[AUDIO OUT] If I sample
the signal at a slower
and slower rate but
it's the same signal,
you can see at some point
that negative frequencies are
going to start crashing into
the positive frequencies.
So you can see that you
don't run into this problem
as long as the sampling rate is
greater than twice the highest
frequency [INAUDIBLE]
So what?
So who cares?
What's so bad about this?
Well, it turns out
that if you sample
at a frequency higher than
twice the bandwidth, the highest
frequency in the
signal, then you
can do something really cool.
You can perfectly reconstruct
the original signal
even though you've sampled
it only discretely.
Put an arbitrary signal in.
You can sample it discretely.
And as long as you've sampled
it at twice the highest
frequency in the
original signal,
you can perfectly reconstruct
the original signal.
Back to this.
Here's our discretely
sampled signal.
There is the spectrum.
It's periodic.
Let's say that the
sampling rate is
more than twice the bandwidth.
How would I reconstruct
the original signal?
But remember that the
convolution theorem
says that by multiplying
the frequency domain,
I'm convolving in
the time domain, OK?
So remember that
this piece right here
was the spectrum of the
original signal, right?
As I sampled it in time,
I added these [AUDIO OUT]
copies at intervals
of the sampling rate.
If I want to get the
original signal back,
I can just put a square
window around this,
keep that, and throw
away all the others.
[INAUDIBLE]
By sampling regularly, I've
just added these other copies.
But they're far enough away
that I can just throw them off.
I can set them to zero.
Now, when I put a square
window in the frequency domain,
what am I doing in
the time domain?
Multiply by a square
window in frequency,
what am I doing in time?
[INAUDIBLE]
So basically what I do is I
take the original signal sampled
regularly in time.
And I just convolve
it with what?
What's the Fourier
transform of a square pulse?
[INAUDIBLE] If I could just
convolve the time domain
[INAUDIBLE] with
a kernel, that's
the Fourier transform
of that square window.
It's just the sync function.
And when I do that, I get
back the original function.
But it's actually easier to do.
Rather than convolving
with a sync function,
it's easier just to multiply
in the frequency domain.
So I can basically get
back my sampled function
at arbitrarily fine [AUDIO OUT]
Here's how you actually do that.
That process is
called zero-padding.
OK, so what you can do is you
can take a function, Fourier
transform it, get the spectrum.
And what the Fourier
transform hands
us back is just this piece
right here [INAUDIBLE]
But what I can do is I can just
move those other peaks away.
So that's what my
FFT sends back to me.
Now what am I going
to do, I'm just
going to push that away and
add zeros in the middle.
Now, inverse Fourier transform,
and [INAUDIBLE] So the sampling
rate is just the number
of frequency samples
I have times delta f.
And here I'm just adding a
bunch of frequency samples
that are zero.
And my new delta t is just going
to be 1 over that new sampling
rate.
Here's an example.
This is a little bit
of code that does it.
Here I've taken a
sine wave at 20 hertz.
You can see 50
millisecond spacing
sampled four times per cycle.
I just run this little
zero-padding algorithm.
And you can see that it
sends me back these red dots.
[INAUDIBLE] have more completely
reconstructed the sine wave
that I sampled.
OK, but you can do
that with any function
as long as the highest frequency
in your original signal
is less than [AUDIO OUT]
half the sampling rate.
[INAUDIBLE]
So zero-padding, so
what I showed you here
is that zero-padding
in the frequency domain
gives you higher
sampling, faster sampling,
in the time domain.
OK, and you can also
do the same thing.
You can also zero-pad
in the time domain
to give finer spacing
in the frequency domain.
FFT samples will
be closer together
in the frequency domain.
OK, so here's how you do that.
So you take a little
piece of data.
You multiply it by
your DPSS taper.
And then just add
a bunch of zeros.
And then take the
Fourier transform
of that longer piece with
all those zeros added to it.
And when you do that, what
you're going to get back
is an FFT that has the
samples in frequency
more finely spaced.
Your delta f is
going to be smaller.
Now, that doesn't [AUDIO OUT]
frequency resolution.
There's no magic getting
around the minimum time
[INAUDIBLE] product.
OK?
But you have more
samples in frequency.
All right, any questions?
[INAUDIBLE] We're going to be
starting a new topic next time.
We're done with
spectral analysis.